[Music]
the growing Harvey Weinstein scandal is
forcing Hollywood to take a hard look at
itself one of the industry's major
unions the Writers Guild of America East
said in a statement sexual harassment
and assault have long been hallmarks of
the entertainment industry thirty five
women have now publicly accused
Weinstein of inappropriate conduct many
alleged victims are hopeful their
stories will prompt a dramatic change
Hollywood insiders say the accusations
against Harvey Weinstein are extreme
examples of the industry's culture of
sexual exploitation let's just say it's
endemic actress Emma Thompson says she
wasn't victimized by Weinstein himself
but that he is one of many offenders
I would spent my 20s trying to get old
men's tongues out of my mouth you know
because they just thought well she's up
for it longtime Hollywood manager Allan
summers tells CBS News Weinstein is not
the only top movie executive who may
have used their position for sex he says
some of these power brokers know they
can pay people off or give them certain
opportunities to ensure they stay quiet
actress Rose McGowan reportedly reached
a 100 thousand dollar settlement with
Weinstein in 1997 after an incident in a
hotel room and says she's been trying to
sound the alarm about him ever since on
Thursday she tweeted at Amazon CEO Jeff
Bezos saying I told the head of your
studio that HW Harvey Weinstein raped me
over and over I said it he said it
hadn't been proven I said I was the
proof now the Weinstein scandal is
prompting others to come forward on
Wednesday Issa Hackett a producer on the
Amazon TV show the man in the high
castle claimed Amazon Studios chief Roy
price repeatedly propositioned her for
sex after a warped dinner Amazon has now
suspended price Weinstein's team has
called his encounters consensual in a
statement to The Hollywood Reporter
Amazon says it takes employee conduct
see
seriously and encourages employees to
raise concerns amazon has not responded
to a request for a comment on Rose
McGowan's accusations the people behind
the Oscars are holding an emergency
meeting tomorrow to discuss the
allegations against Weinstein and
possible actions that they may take as a
result I mean as soon as the story broke
you heard time and time again that he
wasn't the only one this was an
industry-wide problem
my sense is we're going to hear more of
them